This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In Southwest Alaska, two big rivers flow across the subartic Tundra, emptying into the barren sea. Together, the rivers create the Yukon Cuscoquem Delta, an area the size of the state of Illinois. Scattered along the rivers and coast, are 56 Alaska native tribes in communities of mostly a few hundred people. The Tunger River Delta is a wetland, with ponds scattered in every direction and streams and tributaries braiding and weaving between them. That's reporter Anna Rose MacArthur, who lives in the Waikai Delta.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在阿拉斯加西南部，两条大河横穿亚北极苔原，汇入荒凉的大海。这两条河流共同构成了育空-库斯科奎姆三角洲，其面积相当于伊利诺伊州。散布在河流和海岸沿线的是56个阿拉斯加原住民部落，每个社区通常只有几百人。通加河三角洲是一片湿地，池塘星罗棋布，溪流和支流在其中交织穿梭。那是记者安娜·罗斯·麦克阿瑟，她住在怀凯三角洲。
From an airplane, it's hard to tell if there's more water or land below. It's really beautiful. The hub of this region is the city of Bethel, population 6,500. The town is the economic and bureaucratic center of the Delta. It's the place people fly into for medical care, shopping, and work. And the reason they fly is because the entire region is off the road system. That means that while there are roads within communities, there are no roads connecting towns like Bethel to the outside. The land is too boggy to support them.
从飞机上看，很难分辨下面到底是水多还是陆地多。这真的很美。该地区的中心是贝塞尔市，人口6500。这座城镇是三角洲的经济和行政中心。人们飞到这里接受医疗、购物和工作。他们之所以选择飞行，是因为整个地区都没有公路系统。这意味着虽然社区内有道路，但没有公路将贝塞尔这样的城镇与外界连接起来。这里的土地太泥泞，无法支撑道路建设。
The interstates and highways that link most towns and cities in North America don't exist here. The only way in or out of any of the communities in the region, including Bethel, is by plane or boat. In winter, you can also snowmobile or drive a truck along the frozen river, which we call the ice highway. And that presents some interesting challenges when it comes to waste. Because pretty much everything that gets imported into Bethel ultimately stays in Bethel. It comes in by cargo plane or barge,
北美大多数城镇和城市之间连接的州际公路和高速公路在这里并不存在。进出该地区任何社区（包括贝塞尔）的唯一方式就是乘飞机或乘船。冬天，你也可以沿着冰封的河流驾驶雪地摩托或卡车，我们称之为“冰上高速公路”。这在处理垃圾方面带来了一些有趣的挑战。因为几乎所有进口到贝塞尔的东西最终都会留在贝塞尔。它们通过货运飞机或驳船运进来，
and even when something stops working, it's often too expensive and too inconvenient to get it out again. In other places in the United States, trash is thrown away, but in a town scratch from the tundra, unconnected by roads, there is no away. There is only here.
即使某样东西坏了，想要把它运出去也往往太昂贵、太不方便了。在美国的其他地方，垃圾会被扔掉，但在一个从苔原上开辟出来、没有公路连接的城镇里，没有“扔掉”这回事。只有“留在这里”。
And so junk slowly accumulates. People's yards fill with wooden pallets, fishing boobies, oil drums, and tarps with mysterious stuff underneath. It's a common sight throughout rural Alaska. And there's no social stigma attached. No neighborhood committee policing acceptable law into court. Okay.
于是，垃圾慢慢堆积起来。人们的院子里堆满了木托盘、渔船、油桶和盖着神秘物品的防水布。这是阿拉斯加农村地区的常见景象。而且这没有任何社会污名。没有社区委员会来监管所谓的“可接受的法律”。好吧。
This is rolling. Oh, it is, okay. Other people might not see all this junk as a problem, but then there's Diane McAcrane. She's my roommate. She's lived in Bethel for more than 20 years, and she's a very self-motivated person, prone to eccentric obsessions and quests. Now, okay, should I put her in the house
正在录音。哦，是的，好吧。其他人可能不觉得这些垃圾是个问题，但戴安·麦克雷恩不这么看。她是我的室友。她在贝塞尔住了20多年，是一个非常有主见的人，容易产生古怪的执念和追求。现在，好吧，我应该把她关在屋里吗？
because she might do some dog barking? Yeah, that'll be good. Let me do that. Diane has biked 2,000 miles solo across the United States. Twice. She's been arrested for political activism and has been known to stick anti-war flyers between cans
因为她可能会让狗叫？是的，那样会很好。让我这么做。戴安曾独自骑行2000英里横穿美国。两次。她曾因政治活动被捕，还曾因在杂货店的汤罐头和麦片盒之间塞入反战传单而闻名。她还策划了一个贝塞尔溢出垃圾桶的照片集，她觉得这很有趣。我们必须决定第一个地点。大约一年前，她那古怪的执念锁定在了一些许多人注意不到的东西上，就像鱼注意不到水一样。戴安开始痴迷于城镇垃圾问题最明显的表现，
of soup and cereal boxes at the grocery store. She also curates a photo collection of Bethel's overflowing dumpsters that she finds amusing. We have to decide the first place. And about a year ago, her eccentric obsession fixated on something that many people don't notice for the same reason that fish don't notice water. Diane became obsessed with the most visible manifestation
那就是废弃汽车。如果你愿意留意，你会到处看到它们：抛锚、被遗弃，任由它们在风吹雨打中生锈、腐烂。废弃汽车所在的区域各种各样：住宅、随机的停车场、完全偏僻的地方、营业场所。废弃汽车排在路边。
of the town's junk problem, the dead cars. If you care to notice, you see them everywhere, broken down, abandoned, left to rust, and rot out in the elements. The kinds of areas that dead cars get located, homes, random parking lots, totally offbeat locations, places of business. Dead cars line the sides of the roads.
它们填满了人们的院子，散落在公共停车场里。戴安决定要把它们全部数出来。于是她把贝塞尔分成了几个区域。在过去的一年里，她有条不紊地检查了每一条街道、停车场和院子。我一直跟着她。点击声是怎么开始的？她买了一个手持计数器，那种小巧的、像用来统计活动参加人数的那种，
They fill people's yards and sit scattered throughout public parking lots. And Diane has decided she wants to count them all. So she's divided Bethel into sections. Over the course of a year, she's methodically checked every street parking lot in yard. And I've been tacking along. What the clicking began? She bought one of those handheld clickers, a little sober one, like the kind used to count the number of people attending events,
或者用来统计任何东西。所以，那是一辆SUV，旁边还有一辆SUV。福特，福特，福特。好吧。我们数到67了，还没进到一个社区呢。所以。戴安认为这些废弃汽车是更大问题的症状。去年大约有100辆车被送往贝塞尔垃圾填埋场。
or the count anything, really. So there's the SUV, an SUV next to it. Ford, Ford, Ford. Okay. We're up to 67 and we have not hit a neighborhood yet. So. Diane sees the dead cars as a symptom of something bigger. About 100 vehicles were taken to the Bethel landfill last year.
与此同时，大约有300辆车通过驳船运进城里。所有的车都进来了，但它们没有出去，正在我们周围堆积。我们不可能永远逃避这个问题。我的意思是，这种物质主义是有代价的，我也是其中的一部分，所以我并不是说我能免责，因为我不能。不过，我对此思考了很多。
Meanwhile, about 300 vehicles were barged into town. All these cars are coming in, but they're not going out, and they're piling up around us. We're not going to get away with this forever. I mean, there's a price to be paid for this kind of materialism of which I'm part of, so I'm not like saying I'm exempt because I'm not. I give it a lot of thought, though.
我们该如何组织自己来以不同的方式处理这个问题呢？这对我来说是一个迫切的问题。现在那辆红色的卡车看起来不对劲，是吧？点击。我喜欢住在贝塞尔。我喜欢它小城市般的亲密感。我喜欢我可以朝任何方向走几英里，在苔原荒野中搭个帐篷。我喜欢两分钟的停留就被视为交通堵塞。我喜欢夏天钓鲑鱼，秋天采摘野果，冬天为雪橇犬比赛加油。但这个城镇并不适合所有人。只要去机场，
And how can we organize ourselves to handle this differently? It's sort of a burning question for me. Now that red truck doesn't look right, does it? Click. I love living in Bethel. I love its small city intimacy. I love that I can walk in any direction in a couple miles, pitch a tent in the Tundra wilderness. I love that a two-minute stop is considered a traffic jam. I love fishing for salmon in the summer, picking wild berries in the fall, and cheering for sled dog races in the winter. But this town, it isn't for everyone. Just go to the airport and
你就会明白。好吧，我们到了。我们在主航站楼对面的停车场。贝塞尔机场是这个城镇废弃汽车问题最明显的地方。它就像一个生锈车辆的墓地。有传言说，这些车是那些开车到机场、坐上飞机就再也没回来的人留下的。情况太糟糕了，你几乎永远找不到停车位。这一辆报废了，还占了两个车位。
you'll see. Okay, so here we are. We're at the lot across from the main terminal. The Bethel Airport is where the town's dead car problem is most apparent. It's like a graveyard of rusting vehicles. There are rumors the cars were left by people who just drove to the airport, got on a plane, and never looked back. And it's so bad, you can almost never find a parking space. This one is dead and double-part.
这就像是对城镇竖起中指。就像是说，我要把这辆车留在这里，而且我要占两个车位。看看车身，看看车身。那车身太棒了。阿拉斯加交通部负责管理贝塞尔机场，在保持跑道除雪和填补坑洼之间，清理废弃车辆并不是他们的优先事项，这意味着汽车不断堆积，现在成了大麻烦。
That's like a middle finger to the town. It's like, I'm going to leave this car here, and I'm going to double-part. I'm going to take up two spaces while I do it. And look at the, look at the body. That body is excellent. The Alaska Department of Transportation oversees the Bethel Airport and between keeping snow off the runways and filling potholes, removing abandoned cars hasn't been their priority, which means the cars keep accumulating and now they're a major headache.
好吧，首先，关于贝塞尔的机场，你去过贝塞尔并看过布局吗？已经很久了，但是的，我去过那里。香农·麦卡锡是阿拉斯加交通部的发言人。如果我们明显看出车辆被遗弃了，通常你会看到上面有很多雪或灰尘。诸如此类的情况，他们被要求张贴30天的清理通知。
Okay, first of all, with the airport here in Bethel, have you been out to Bethel and seen the layout? It's been a long time, but yes, I have been out there. Shannon McCarthy is a spokesperson for the Alaska Department of Transportation. If it is becomes obvious to us that a car has been abandoned, and often times you'll see lots of snow on it, or lots of dust on it. That kind of thing, they are required to post it for removal for 30 days.
30天过后，我们实际上必须把它们带到我们的车间，为处置做准备。这意味着排空液体、拆除电池，然后把车辆送到垃圾场。这是在贝塞尔处置汽车的正确方式。州政府处理每辆车要花费50美元，因为找不到车主。你知道，我们确实尝试联系，但通常如果有人秘密处置车辆，他们往往不会留下好的联系方式。
And then once the 30 days has passed, we actually have to bring them to our shop and we have to prepare them for disposal. That means draining the fluids, removing the battery, and taking the vehicle to the dump. That's the proper way to dispose of a car in Bethel. It costs the state $50 for each car they have to deal with because the owners are nowhere to be found. You know, we do try to make contact, but oftentimes if someone is disposing of a vehicle clandestinely, if you will, they oftentimes don't leave good contact information.
联系方式不再有效。所以不幸的是，我们无法经常收回这些成本。天哪。你要知道，我们已经数到188辆车了。我们甚至还没有……什么？我们甚至还没有……
The contact information no longer is valid. So unfortunately, we're not able to recoup those costs very frequently. Oh my. Just so you know, we're up to 188 cars. We haven't even... What? We haven't even...
还没有真正触及贝塞尔的表面。让我们再过一遍这些迹象，比如区分废弃汽车的明显迹象。轮胎周围长满了草，草长得很高，说明草开始生长已经有一段时间了。当然，真正明显的是像煎饼一样的轮胎，轮胎完全脱离了轮辋，窗户全碎了，然后也许我知道那辆车一年没动过了。或者它陷进了土里。
Still haven't really scratched the surface of Bethel. Let's go over the signs again, like the tell-tale signs that distinguish the car. There's grass growing up around the tires, and the grass is tall enough that it took a while for the grass to begin growing. Of course the real obvious pancake tires, tires that are completely off the rim, the windows are all broken out and then maybe I know that that car has never moved for a year. Or it's sunk into the dirt.
是的，它开始沉入大地本身。嗯，这就是可悲之处。哦，看那辆漂亮的雪佛兰。那美丽的颜色。并非贝塞尔所有的废弃汽车都被遗弃并留给别人处理，比如机场里的那些。有些是被精心照料的，打算在未来用于更大的用途。比如阿吉·格雷戈里家旁边的那些车。
Yeah, it started to sink into earth itself. Well, that's the sad thing. Oh, look at that beautiful Chevy. That beautiful color. Not all dead cars in Bethel are abandoned and left for someone else to deal with, like the ones at the airport. Some are carefully curated, meant to be used for a greater purpose in the future. Like the cars beside Aggie Gregory's house.
好吧，你能告诉我院子里这些车的故事吗？有三辆车就停在我们的地盘上，其中几辆是一样的，所以我们用一辆作为另一辆的零件。废弃汽车在这里的院子里很常见，因为拆卸零件来修理其他车辆的情况经常发生。等等，那是你打算修理的那辆吗？银色的那辆？我们是打算修理，但我不知道这是否会发生。如果你不修理它，你觉得它会停在那里多久？这是个好问题。阿吉说他们最终想处理掉这些车，这样他们就有
Okay, so will you tell me the story about these cars in the yard? There's three that are just sitting on our property and a couple of them are the same and so we use one for parts for the other one. Dead cars are a common feature in yards here because cannibalizing parts to fix other vehicles happens all the time. And so wait, is that the the one that you're supposed to fix up? The silver one? We're supposed to, but I don't know if that's going to ever happen. If you don't get it fixed up how long? Do you think it's going to sit there? That's a good question. Aggie says that they eventually want to get rid of the cars so they have
空间停放他们的旧船，因为他们计划买一艘新船，并把旧船拆了当零件。他们有两辆雪地摩托也是出于同样的原因。我想有些零件很难买到，而且运进来要花钱，所以为什么不留着它们并使用它们呢？阿拉斯加农村地区以其机智的资源利用而闻名。你不能生活在一个如此偏远、东西运送时间如此之长且成本如此之高的地方而不发挥创造力。人们倾向于长时间保留他们的东西，即使是坏掉的东西。
room to park their old boat because they plan to get a new boat and strip the old one for parts. They have two snowmobiles for the same reason. Some parts are harder to get, I guess, and it costs money to ship in, so why not keep them and use them? Rural Alaska is famous for its scrappy resourcefulness. You can't live in a place that's so remote where things take so long to get and cost so much money without creativity. People tend to hold on to their stuff for a long time, even broken stuff.
很少有东西被扔掉，通常如果还能用，我们就会重复利用。大卫·菲卡正在帮忙修理阿吉和她丈夫的一辆卡车。大卫来自马歇尔，那是育空河上贝塞尔以北的一个小村庄。这是一个机械世界，我敢肯定。很多雪地摩托、四轮摩托，我们从小就在这种环境下长大。大多数人自然而然地学会了拆解东西，然后必须把它们装回去。是的。大卫刚刚修好了他朋友的02年道奇达科塔卡车的球头。它们是车轮和悬架之间的枢轴。
Very little gets thrown away, usually if it's good enough we'll reuse. David Ficka is helping to repair a truck that belongs to Aggie and her husband. David is from Marshall, a small village north of Bethel on the Yukon River. It's a mechanical world, I'm sure. A lot of snow machines, four wheelers, we kind of grow up around it. And most of the guys will become natural to add it to just start taking things apart and then they have to go back together. Yeah. David has just finished changing the ball joints on his friend's O2 Dodge Dakota truck. They're the pivots between the wheels and the suspension.
通常，这些接头可以使用大约10年，但在贝塞尔，大约只有两年。这是因为这里的道路出了名的糟糕。有时，看起来坑洼比路面还多。变暖的冬天让情况变得更糟。气温不是下降并保持在冰点以下，而是忽高忽低。当冰融化时，水进入道路的所有缝隙。当它重新结冰时，它会膨胀，使裂缝越来越大。外部的基础设施是通过殖民带来的，在这里并不太好用。
Usually, these joints would last about 10 years, but in Bethel, it's more like two. That's because the roads here are notoriously bad. Sometimes, it seems like there's more pothole than road. And warming winters have made them even worse. Instead of the temperature dropping and staying below freezing, it goes up and down. As the ice melts, water gets into all the nooks and crannies of the road. When it re-freezes, it expands, making the cracks bigger and bigger. The infrastructure of the outside, it arrived through colonization, and it doesn't work so well here.
随着时间的推移，地面经历了无数次的冻结和解冻，路面形成了这些巨大的隆起。这就像坐过山车，骑自行车很有趣，但对汽车来说很痛苦。有几声安静的点击声是个不错的音效。因为现在听众知道这是怎么回事了。让我问问这些女孩。哦不，好吧。嘿，那辆绿色的车能开吗？
Over time, the ground has frozen and thawed so many times that the pavement has created these giant heaths. It's like a rollercoaster ride, fun on a bike, but hard on a car. It's a nice sound effect to have a few quiet clicks. Because by now the audience knows what it's all about. Let me ask these girls. Oh no, okay. Hey, does that green car work?
那辆绿色的车能开吗？我不这么认为。女孩们现在握手。我想是吧。看看那个“我想是吧”。女孩们从屋里出来。我想是吧。看看那里的生长情况。看看下面的生长情况。所以我数到869了。在汽车报废并最终被遗弃在路边
Does that green car work? I don't think so. Girl shake hands right now. I think so. Look at the think so. Girl shake out of the house. I think so. Look at the growth. Look at the growth under there. So I'm at 869. Before cars die and end up abandoned on the side of the road
或某人的院子里之前，它们通常会经过几任车主，随着从一个人传到另一个人手中而不断恶化。我的一个朋友曾经花500美元买了一辆不能倒车的吉普车。我们把这样的车称为“贝塞尔破烂车”。我个人决定放弃买破烂车，转而骑自行车和打车，因为这片废弃车辆的土地也有着繁荣的出租车行业。出租车是关键的共享资源。它们被不断涌入的
or in someone's yard, they typically cycle through a few owners, deteriorating as they pass from one person to the next. A friend of mine once bought a Jeep for $500 that couldn't reverse. We call cars like these Bethel-Beaters. I personally have decided to forego a beater in favor of biking and taking taxis, because this land of abandoned vehicles also has a thriving cab industry. Cubs are a critical shared resource. They're heavily relied upon by the constant influx of
来自附近村庄的旅客所严重依赖。一旦人们乘飞机或乘船来参加购物预约和商务活动，他们就需要一种出行方式。所以你到处都能看到出租车。事实上，曼哈顿并不是美国的出租车之都。贝塞尔才是。按人均算，反正。所以是的，按人均计算，贝塞尔拥有美国最多的出租车，总共有59辆。贝塞尔总共有59辆出租车。
travelers from nearby villages. Once people arrive by plane or boat for their shopping appointments and business, they need a way to get around. And so you see cabs everywhere. In fact, Manhattan isn't the cab capital of the US. Bethel is. Procapita, anyway. So yes, per capita, Bethel has the most cabs in the United States, but there's 59. 59 cabs total in Bethel.
这意味着每110人就有一辆出租车。纳伊姆·沙巴尼是贝塞尔最大的出租车公司“库斯科出租车”的共同所有人。我们平均每45秒就有一个电话。最繁忙的时间是早上，人们去上班，孩子们去上学，人们去机场。然后是当天晚些时候，人们下班时，最后是晚上，在宾果游戏、晚餐和杂货店关门之间。贝塞尔的出租车平均每天行驶200英里，每天200英里，或者大约
That means there's one cab for every 110 people. Naim Shabani is the co-owner of Bethel's largest cab company, Cusco Cab. We average a call every 45 seconds. The busiest times are mornings when people are getting to work, kids are getting to school, and people are going to the airport. Then later in the day, when people get off work, and finally at night, between Bingo and Dane and the grocery stores closing. On average a cab in Bethel does 200 miles a day, 200 miles a day, or about
每月6000英里，这就是贝塞尔出租车在轮班结束时的平均里程表读数。在仅有的36英里道路上行驶这么多，纳伊姆说这很有趣。大多数行程都是共享的，有很多常客，许多司机已经开了好几年了。你可以和他们聊聊他们的生活，反之亦然，所以一天过得很快。这就像在电梯里待了12个小时。即使是住在育空-库斯科奎姆三角洲并拥有自己车辆的人也经常使用出租车。比如当道路结冰时，车主
6,000 miles a month, that is the average odometer reading at the end of the ship for a cab in Bethel. All that driving on only 36 miles of road, Nyeem says it's fun. Most rides are shared and there are a lot of regular customers that many drivers have been driving for years. You get to catch up with them and their life and vice versa so the day does go by rather quickly. It's kind of like being an elevator for 12 hours. Even people who live in the YK Delta and have their own vehicles regularly use caps. Like when the roads are icy and vehicle owners
不想冒着汽车滑进沟里的风险。既然可以乘坐纳伊姆的出租车，为什么要拿自己的车冒险呢？当然，这意味着纳伊姆的出租车受损严重。他说它们平均能用三年。我喜欢把贝塞尔的一些车辆看作是“一次性手机”，你买它直到话费耗尽，然后把它扔掉，再去买另一部。戴安在贝塞尔拥有过三辆车。
don't want to risk their cars sliding into a ditch. Why take the chance with your own vehicle when you can just take one of name's taxis? Of course, that means name's taxis take a beating. He says they last on average three years. I like to think of some vehicles in Bethel as like burner cell phones where you buy it until the minutes run out and then you toss it out and go get another one. Diane has owned three cars in Bethel.
有一天我们出去统计时，发现了她的第一辆车。哦，哦，天哪。哦，天哪。那是我的第一辆贝塞尔车！那是我在贝塞尔的第一辆车，上面还有“占领苔原”的贴纸。哦，天哪。“占领苔原”是一个由戴安发起的单人运动。那是我的第一辆车，看看它变成了什么样。描述一下你看到了什么。
One day when we were out counting we found her first one. Oh, oh, oh my gosh. Oh, oh my gosh. That was my first Bethel car! That was my first car in Bethel and it's got the Occupy the Tundra sticker. Oh my gosh. Occupy the Tundra was a movement of one, started by Diane. That was my first vehicle and look what's become of it. Describe what you're seeing.
嗯，我的意思是轮胎报废了。其中一个窗户被打碎了。后转向灯完全悬挂着。哦，我的天哪。点击。贝塞尔的“一次性经济”，即汽车被使用后被扔在路边，是相对较新的。贝塞尔地区是美国领土最后被殖民的地方之一。它没有像大型金矿、鲸鱼或海獭那样的自然资源来
Well, I mean the tires shot. One of the windows busted out. The rear blinker thing is completely hang dangling. Oh my goodness gracious. Click. Bethel's disposable economy where cars get used and then dumped by the side of the road, it's relatively new. The Bethel area was one of the final places colonized in the U.S. territory. It didn't have the natural resources like large gold deposits, whales, or sea otters to
吸引定居者。这种晚期殖民是尤皮克文化依然如此强大的原因之一。这就是为什么尤皮克语是美国为数不多的以第一语言使用的土著语言之一，也是为什么尤皮克人仍然在他们的祖先土地上狩猎、捕鱼和采集的原因。70多岁和80多岁的尤皮克长者经历了快速的文化转型。他们出生在一个在很大程度上仍然是游牧狩猎采集的社会。
lure settlers. This late colonization is one of the reasons why the U.P.C. culture remains so strong. It's why U.P.C. is one of the few indigenous languages in the U.S. spoken as a first language, and it's why U.P.C pick people still hunt, fish, and gather on their ancestral lands. You pick elders in their 70s and 80s have lived through a rapid cultural transformation. They were born into what was still a largely nomadic hunter-gatherer society.
现在他们带着智能手机。他们从喂养狗队变成了给雪地摩托加油，从住在草皮屋里变成了用柴油加热框架房屋。在下48州花费了数百年的转型，在这些长者的有生之年内就发生了。其中一位长者是埃丝特·格林。埃丝特，你能自我介绍一下吗？我们现在认识埃丝特·格林，她要去花园了。你可以去花园。
And now they carry smartphones. They went from feeding dog teams to gassing up snowmobiles, from living in sod houses to heating frame tombs with diesel fuel. A transformation that took hundreds of years and the lower 48 occurred within these elders' lifetimes. One of these elders is Esther Green. Esther, will you introduce yourself? We know Esther Green now will go to the garden. You can go to the garden.
埃丝特，你哪年出生的？你多大了？1938年。81岁。埃丝特·格林在她81年的生命中看到了很多变化。她在一个附近的村庄开始生活，小时候搬到了贝塞尔。埃丝特·格林在她81年的生命中看到了很多变化。她在一个附近的村庄开始生活，小时候搬到了贝塞尔。她看着贝塞尔从几百人增长到几千人，她看到了随之而来的所有车辆。
Esther, what year were you born? How old are you? 1938. 81. Esther Green has seen a lot of change in her 81 years. She started life in a nearby village and moved to Bethel as a young girl. Esther Green has seen a lot of change in her 81 years. She started life in a nearby village and moved to Bethel as a young girl. She watched Bethel grow from hundreds of people to thousands of people, and she's seen all the vehicles that have come with them.
我们开车去了贝塞尔的一个海滩。现在是退潮。现在是退潮。是的。退潮很厉害。这里曾经有一道完全由废弃汽车组成的防波堤，只是堆在那里以阻止侵蚀。它看起来就像一堆废弃汽车堆在一起吗？是的。嗯。
We drove down to a beach in Bethel. It's low tide. It's low tide. Yeah. It's really low. There used to be a sea wall here made entirely of dead cars, just dump there to stop erosion. Did it look like just a pile of dead cars stacked on top of each other? Yeah. Mm-hmm.
废弃汽车防波堤阻止了侵蚀，但阿拉斯加州环境保护部在1981年认为它是一个环境危险，因为它会向河流泄漏电池酸和汽油，几年后这些车被移走了。在那个时候，这个海滩是少数几个可以安全停放船只的地方之一。到处都是腐烂、生锈的油箱，混杂着旧车。在尤皮克传统中，所有非人类创造的东西都有“尤克”。“尤克”翻译过来就是“人”。植物、动物、水、岩石等等都有“尤克”。
The dead car sea wall stopped the erosion, but the Alaska Department of Environmental Conservation deemed it an environmental danger in 1981 for leaking battery acid and gasoline into the river, and the cars were removed a few years later. This beach was one of the few safe places to park a boat during that time. No rotten, rusty, gas tank everywhere mixed with old carves. In the eupik tradition, everything that isn't created by humans has a yuk. Yuk translates to a person. Plants, animals, water, rocks, and so on all have yukes.
这是一种精神、一种动画、一种意识。万物皆有灵，万物皆有耳，它们能看见，能感觉到，就像我们人类一样。当我们把车辆扔在景观中，任由它们腐烂时，埃丝特说这会导致破坏。天哪，这一辆。天哪。这是一个问题。
It's a spirit, an animation, an awareness. Chakdama rami, jee dung khtok, chakdama rami, dang duk. Everything around us has ears, and they can see, and they can feel feel just like us human beings. And when we throw vehicles across the landscape, leaving them to rot, Esther says it causes a disruption. God, this one here. God. This is a problem.
我不认为这只是阿拉斯加的问题。这更像是世界的一个缩影。你知道，我们生产，我们生产，我们消费，然后它会发生什么？它留在这里。它留在地球上。我认为这是一个很好的观点，因为我认为这与资本主义和物质主义有关。你是对的。这并不是贝塞尔特有的。只是我们有一个独特的背景，所以它变得清晰可见。是的，让我把这些废弃的小狗都拍下来。但我们到了。轮胎瘪了，草长出来了。嗯，我想这将是我的最后一次点击。
I don't think that is just Alaska. This is more of a microcosm of the world. You know, we produce, we produce, and we consume, and then what happens to it? It stays here. It stays on the planet. I think that's a good point, because I think it's related to capitalism and materialism. And you're right. This isn't particularly unique to Bethel. It's just we have a unique context, so it kind of it's all visible. Yeah, let me just catch all these dead puppies here. But here we are. Tire's flat, grass growing. Um, I think that's's gonna be my final click.
好吧，943。结束了。戴安说她可能会给报纸写一封关于她汽车统计的信，或者她说她可能会在社区会议上展示她的发现，或者只是发在社交媒体上。也许这会引发一场对话。但实际上，统计只是为了她自己，一种满足她对一个她观察到的问题的好奇心的方式，如果没有系统来解决它，它只会继续增长。明年夏天会有更多的车辆通过驳船运进贝塞尔。它们会不断到来，不断报废，不断堆积。
All right, 943. That's the end. Diane says she might write a letter to the newspaper about her car count, or she says she might present her findings at a community meeting, or just post it on social media. Maybe it'll spark a conversation. But really, the count was just for her, a way to satisfy her curiosity about a problem that she's observed that with no system to address it, we'll only continue to grow. More vehicles will be barged into Bethel next summer. They'll keep coming, keep dying, and keep piling up.
尽管贝塞尔感觉很独特，但事实并非如此。我们都把东西扔掉。在许多情况下，它最终进入了远离我们意识的垃圾填埋场。但垃圾仍然存在于我们中间，在地球上。它们都在某个地方堆积。在贝塞尔，我们对那个地方在哪里没有幻想。它就在我们周围。我们生活在其中。哦，看那辆吉普车。那辆吉普车是个“枪手”。吉普。吉普是个“枪手”。944。
And as much as Bethel feels unique, it's not. We all throw things away. In many cases, it ends up in a landfill, far removed from our consciousness. But the junk remains among us, on the earth. It's all piling up somewhere. In Bethel, we have no illusions about where that place is. It's around us. We're living in it. Oh, look at that Jeep. That Jeep is a gunner. cheap. cheap is a gunner. 944.
点击声还在继续。哈哈，哦不！休息后请继续收听完全不同的内容，来自Radio Topia的全新节目的扩展预告。既然你现在正在听我说话，我知道你是《99%隐形》的听众，但我也希望你是Radio Topia其他许多节目的粉丝，那是我与PRX共同创立的播客网络。好吧，Radio Topia刚刚推出了一个新节目，它真的很酷。
the clicking goes on. haha oh no! Stay tuned after the break for something completely different, an extended preview of a brand new show from Radio Topia. Since you're listening to me right now, I know you are a 99% invisible listener, but I also hope you're a fan of many of the other shows in Radio Topia, that's the podcast network I co-founded with PRX. Well, Radio Topia has just launched a new show and it's really, really cool.
它叫《乘客名单》，是一部系列音频剧，一部悬疑惊悚片，关于一架失踪的飞机、一场全球阴谋，以及一个年轻女子寻找真相的旅程。主演是凯莉·玛丽·陈，她太棒了，还有科林·摩根、罗伯·本内迪克特和百老汇传奇人物帕蒂·卢波恩。我已经听完了全部内容，因为我有特权，我告诉你这个节目非常引人入胜，它充满了精彩的剧本、惊人的声音设计，我知道你会喜欢的。我现在要为你播放一小段，我想当你听到这个时，你会想知道接下来会发生什么并订阅它。来自Radio Topia，这是《乘客名单》。嗨，你好，我们这里有个孩子，27号登机口似乎迷路了。
It's called Passendralist, and it's a serialized audio drama, a mystery thriller, about a missing plane, a global conspiracy, and a young woman's quest to figure out what happened. It stars Kelly Marie Tran, she's so good, Colin Morgan, Rob Benedict, and Broadway legend, Patty Lupone. I've heard the whole thing because I have privileges and I'm telling you this show is riveting, it's full of great writing, amazing sound design and I know you're gonna love it. I'm gonna play a little bit for you right now and I think when you hear this you're going to need to know what happens next and subscribe. From Radio Topia, here's passenger list. Hi, hello, we've got a child here, GATE 27 seems lost.
什么？一个大约，嗯，抱住你。我会说，我会说，嗯，五岁。他，嗯，在航站楼里徘徊，拿着一盒果汁和一个背包。你有护照吗？没有。你有没有呼叫他的父母？是的，好几次。好的。他叫什么名字？
A what? A child who is about, um, held you. I'd say, I'd say, um, five. He was, um, wandering to the terminal with a cotton of juice and a backpack. Did you have a passport? No. Have you put out a call for his parents? Yes, several. Okay. What's his name?
打扰一下。打扰一下。嗨。你叫什么名字？布拉特法。你的妈妈和爸爸在哪里？妈妈。布拉特法，布拉特法。你的妈妈和爸爸在哪里？妈妈？爸爸？布拉特法。
Excuse me. Excuse me. Hi. What's your name? Bratfa. Where's your mummy and daddy? Mama. Bratfa, Bratfa. Where's your mummy and daddy? Mama? Papa? Bratfa.
那是他的姓吗？那是你的姓吗？那是你的姓吗？布拉特法。这是厄尼，请，我的英语。你在哪里？27号登机口。好的，把他带到安检处。我在那里见你。好的。
Is that his surname? Is that your last name? Is that your last name? Bratfa. This is Ernie, please, my English. Where are you? Grade 27. Okay, bring him to security. I'll see you there. Okay.
再见。所以，这是希思罗机场乘客福利官伊芙琳·戴维斯。今天是2018年4月12日。现在是晚上8点36分。这是……布拉珀。你想喝点什么吗，布拉瓦？她需要那个比尼。
Goodbye. So, this is Heathrow Airport passenger welfare officer Evelyn Davis. Today's date is April 12th, 2018. It's currently 8.36pm. This is... ...brapper. Do you want something to drink Brava? She needs to that beany.
他说了什么？他想要他的妈妈。布拉瓦，你妈妈说什么？加萨，迈克，吉德，吉德，吉德，吉德会分享它。迈克，G-妈妈，达科，爸爸。你为什么从布拉德福德来？你知道吗？萨莫让你这么做。他说他是坐飞机来的。你知道你住在哪里吗？我查了布拉德福德的入境乘客名单。
What did he say? He wants his mother. What's your mum saying Brava? Gasa, Mike, Gide, Gide, Gide, Gide will share it. Mike, G-Mama, Daco, Daddy. Why did you come from Bradford? Do you know? So Samo let you do that. He says he came on a plane. Do you know where you live? I checked the incoming passenger list for Bradford.
这里只有一个，在锁里。看起来他是飞进来的。你住在哪里？我查了布拉德福德的入境乘客名单，这里只有一个，在锁里。看起来他是今天和他妈妈玛丽亚·埃利安从纽约飞进来的。那是你妈妈的名字吗，布拉德福德？玛丽亚？我想那是一个点头。让我们为玛丽亚发出寻人启事。是的，好吧，看，这就是问题所在。他们预订了飞往保加利亚索非亚的航班。更好，这样我们就能回到拉维塔。
Only one here, it's in lock. It looks like he flew in. Where you live? I checked the incoming passenger list for Bradfur, only one here, it's in luck. It looks like he flew in from New York today with his mother, Maria Ellian. Is that your mum's name, Bradfur? Maria? I think that was a nod. Let's get the page out for Maria. Yeah, well, see that's a thing. They were booked on a flight to Sofia, Bulgaria. Even better so we can get back to Ravita.
不，等等。航班已经起飞了。玛丽亚不在上面。所以她还在机场吗？不。她在一架飞回纽约的航班上。大西洋航空，702次航班。她应该会在肯尼迪机场降落。
No, hold on. The flight already left. Maria wasn't on it. So she's still in the airport then. No. She's on a flight back to New York. Atlantic Airlines, flight 702. She should be landing at JFK.
我不确定她是否会……在一架飞回纽约的航班上。大西洋航空，702次航班。她应该会在纽约时间晚上11点在肯尼迪机场降落。好的，我们需要……你好，你能帮我接通肯尼迪机场大西洋航空的安检处吗？好的，请稍等。是肯尼迪机场。好的，请稍等。是肯尼迪机场。好的。
I'm not sure if she's going to's on a flight back to New York. Atlantic Airlines, flight 702. She should be landing at JFK at 11 p.m. New York time. Okay, we need to... Hello, can you connect me with security at Atlantic Airlines, JFK? Yes, I'll hold. It's JFK. Yes, I'll hold. It's JFK. Yes.
爸爸，别担心，亲爱的。我们会找到你的，妈妈。这就是飞机坠毁的方式。希思罗机场，预计在7.02之后。大西洋航班是7.02。对于雷达与飞机的联系，以及机上人员的损失。但我认为这里的每个人都在为最坏的情况做准备。这一点确实仍然是一个谜。失踪是由于机械故障、飞行员失误还是恐怖主义。当委员会负责战争时，
Papa, don't worry sweetie. We're going to find you, mummy. This is how a plane has crashed. Heathrow, was expected in a more than 7.02. The Atlantic flight is 7.02. For its radar contact with the plane, with the loss of people on the board. But I think everyone here is bracing themselves for the West. This point really is still a mystery. The disappearance is due to mechanical problems, pilot error or even terrorism. When the commission was in charge of the war,
战争飞机失踪是不正常的。我认为我们现在有充分的理由预计这不会是一个好的结果。暴风雨离机。一些失踪乘客的亲属被强行带离新闻发布会。卫星图像显示飞机在被怀疑的鸟类之前戏剧性地改变了航向，我的鸟类是古代鸟击。这很可能是原因。飞机在33000英尺。我们知道NF2，我们引擎，撞击了一群鹅，飞行员报告说。
the war airplane to disappear is not normal. I think we have at this hour every reason to expect that this is not going to be a good outcome. Tempest off-frame. Some relatives of missing passengers were forcefully removed from a news conference. In the satellite images show the plane changing course dramatically to the course before by a suspected bird, my births were the ancient bird strike. This was likely reason. It's the plain with me to 33,000 feet. We know that the NF2, we engine, stracker, a flock of geese, the pilot report.
我们必须继续前进。生命是脆弱的。也许现在是我们所有人停下来，转向我们所爱的人并将他们紧紧拥抱的时候了，因为生命。好吧，生命是脆弱的。控制。你好？嗨，我想联系格雷格·福特。是我。我叫凯特琳·莱，我在Facebook上给你发过关于那个航班的消息。
We have to move on. Life is a fragile thing. Maybe this is a time for all of us to pause and turn to those we love and hold them close because life. Well, life is fragile. control. Hello? Hi, I'm trying to reach Greg Ford. That's me. My name's Caitlin. Lay, I messaged you on Facebook about the flight.
对。你能等一下吗？是的。你能等一下吗？是的。谢谢。嘿伙计们，我有个问题。我想带给你。我接下来还需要你吗？抱歉，我只是得找个安静的地方说话。等一下。所以，是的。那个带着孩子的女人。是的，你说你和她坐同一架入境航班，对吧？
Right. Can you just hang on one second? Yeah. Can you just hang on one second? Yeah. Thank you. Hey guys, I got a question. I want to bring it to you. Do you need me more while I was next? Sorry, I just had to find a quick or quiet spot to talk. Hold on. So, yeah. The woman with that kid. Yeah, you said you were on an incoming flight with her, right?
你坐在她和她儿子旁边。这是为了什么？我的兄弟康纳在702次航班上。哦，天哪。我很抱歉。是的，不是。是，谢谢。我只是想把这一切拼凑起来。
You sat next to her and her son. What is this for? My brother, Connor, was on 702. Oh, God. I'm so sorry. Yeah, it's not. It's, thank you. I'm just trying to piece all this together.
所以如果有什么你能告诉我的。是的，当然。就像我在帖子里说的那样，我碰巧坐在那个带着孩子的女人旁边，在飞往伦敦的航班上，在她重新登机之前。是的。对。但你说她直接登上了另一架飞机，是的。对。但你说她接到了一个电话。
So if there's anything that you could tell me. Yeah, totally. Like I said in my post, I just happened to be sitting next to the woman with the kid on the fight into London, before she got right back on board the other one. And yeah. Right. But you said that she got right back on board the other one and yeah. Right. But you said that she got a phone call.
是的。如果不是因为当时发生的所有事情，我不会多想，但我希望你不是因为被所有的猜测冒犯了才打电话。不，一点也不。我只是……我实际上……看到其他人也有疑问其实很安慰，所以……抱歉。总之，回到这个女人身上。对，所以我们在飞行过程中并没有怎么说话。我只是问她关于她儿子的事，问他是否开始游泳了，我很抱歉，我很抱歉。是的，我只是想礼貌一点，她并没有怎么说英语。当我们降落在希思罗机场，每个人都打开手机等等的时候，
Yeah. I wouldn't have thought anything of it if it weren't for all the things going on in the situation, but I hope you're not calling because you're offended by all the speculation. No, not at all. I'm just... I'm actually... it's actually comforting to see that other people have questions, so... Sorry. Anyway, back to this woman. Right, so it's not like we talked much during the flight. I just asked her about her son and if he'd started swimming yet, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. Yeah, I was just trying to be polite and she didn't really speak much English. And as soon as we landed a Heathrow and everyone's turning their phones on and everything,
她接到了这个电话。我记得，她只是僵住了。所以她很害怕。你能听到她在说什么吗？不，我的意思是她用她说的任何语言在说话。但肯定是的，她很害怕。我会说，吓坏了。她把孩子抱在怀里，只是在他耳边低语。我们周围的人都在解开安全带，打开行李架
she gets this phone call. And I remember, she just froze. So she was scared. Could you hear what she was talking about? No, I mean she was talking in whatever she was speaking in. But definitely, yes, she was scared. I'd terrified, I'd say. And she took the kid in her arms and was just whispering in his ear. And all around us people were unbuckling seat belts and opening the bins
把箱子拉下来等等。她只是坐在那里，盯着前方，抱着孩子，她的脸像鬼一样白。当她进入航站楼时发生了什么？我不知道，我没有跟着她，但当我在移民排队时，那是一个很大的队伍，很多航班同时到达。我注意到她独自站在那里。我记得当时在想，孩子呢？我的意思是，如果不是因为所有关于，你知道，我的意思是，不是完全的阴谋，但
and pulling down two cases and all that. And she's just sitting there staring straight ahead with the kidney horns and her face was like ghost white. What happened when she got into the terminal? I don't know I didn't follow her but when I was in line for the immigration line it was this big big line and a lot of flights had come in all at the same time. And I noticed her standing there all alone. And I remember thinking, where's the kid? I mean, I wouldn't have even remembered it if it weren't for all this talk about, you know, I mean, not a conspiracy exactly, but
发生了奇怪的事情。但是的，那有帮助吗？我想是的。是的，谢谢。你不相信关于那群鹅的事情吗？我不知道我相信什么。是的，这对你的家人来说一定很难。是的，仍然是。
something weird going on. But yeah, does that help at all? I think so. Yes, thank you. You don't believe this thing about the flock of geese? I don't know what I believe. Yeah, I must have been really hard for your family. Yeah, it still is.
是的，仍然是。所以，她只是转过身，重新登记了一架飞往纽约的航班，对吧？我不知道，我猜。没有孩子，我的意思是，什么样的母亲会那样做，对吧？你认为她和导致飞机坠毁的事情有关吗？是的，我认为我们不知道的事情还有很多。对，对。是的，我的意思是，我们现在算什么，对吧？你好？嗨，是安娜·德拉戈夫吗？你是谁？
Yeah, it still is. So what, she just turned right around and checked back into a flight to New York, right? I don't know, I guess. Without the kid, I mean, what kind of mother would do that, right? You think she had something to do with, you know, what brought the plane down? Yeah, I think that there's a lot that we don't know. Right, right. Yeah, I mean, what are any of us now, right? Hello? Hi, is this Anna Dragoff? Who is this?
抱歉，你不认识我。我叫凯特琳·莱。我兄弟在702次航班上。是的。你姐姐也在飞机上，对吧？我希望我们能……我帮不了你。《乘客名单》的前两集现在已经出来了。前往www.passengerslist.org了解更多信息。或者在您最喜欢的播客应用程序中搜索《乘客名单》。
I'm sorry, you don't know me. My name is Caitlin Leigh. My brother was on 7-0-2. Yes. Your sister was on the plane as well, correct? I was hoping that we could... I can't help you. The first two episodes of Passengers List are out now. Head to www.passengerslist.org to find out more. Or just search for Passengers lists in your favorite podcast app.
《99%隐形》本周由安娜·罗斯·麦克阿瑟制作，德莱尼·霍尔编辑，由奇迹制造者Sirifusif进行混音和技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队的其他成员是乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心Radio Row制作。也许在我说这些年的过程中，你已经想过，美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心
99% Invisible was produced this week by Anna Rose MacArthur, edited by Delaney Hall, mixed in tech production by the miracle worker Sirifusif, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team is Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee, Chris Barube, Avery Trouffleman, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Maybe over the years of me saying that, you've thought, beautiful downtown Oakland, California
印在T恤上会很好看。那么，我的朋友，你应该去9ipi.org/store，我为你准备了一份礼物。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI org。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。但你可以更多地了解阿拉斯加贝塞尔，看看那座疯狂的防波堤
would look really good on a t-shirt. Well, then, my friend, you should go to 9ipi.org slash store, and I've got a treat for you. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But you can get to know Bethel Alaska a little bit more and see a picture of the crazy sea
由废弃汽车制成。世界上谁会认为这是一个好主意。在99pi.org Radio to PO from PRX你。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
wall made of dead cars. Who in the world thought that was a good idea. at 99pi.org Radio to PO from PRX you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
用废弃汽车堆成的墙。到底是谁觉得这是个好主意。在 99pi.org，由 PRX 提供的 Radio to PO。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。